each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's my great pleasure today to
introduce Steve Easterbrook from the
University of Toronto he is quite the
rarity in software engineering circles
he is a software engineering professor
that likes to study how software is
actually made by watching it being done
so today he's going to show us how he's
watched climate scientists produce
software and what it looks like from
their perspective okay thank you I'm
gonna wear how well you can hear me I
assume the mic is is picking up
something so what I'm going to talk
about today is a two month observational
study that I did last year at the UK Met
Office hadley center looking at
scientific software and how it's built
in this case a large hunk of a fortran
so what I'll attempt to do whoops I'm
confusing myself now is try and explain
why climate scientists build software
what this software is for what is it
supposed to do for them a little bit I
give a little bit of the background of
how what this software is what's the
what's the domain and what are they
simulating and then the the core of the
study is how do they build software what
are their software practices and I want
to draw out some of what they do that I
find interesting from a software
engineering perspective and then talk
about well can we as software engineers
help these scientists and if the
answer's no and in many respects
unexpectedly it is no what else can we
be doing and how else can can we engage
with climate scientists given the
importance of the field so my motivating
question going into this study was I'm a
software engineering professor these
people build software largely without
any software engineering training surely
we must be able to help
we know how to build software so that
was my motivation going into the study
to look for places where software
engineering tools and techniques could
help these people and going into it we
didn't know much about what what the
software engineering practices are
amongst computational scientists there
have been a few previous studies not
very detailed studies and they're only
probably I can count them on one hand
and they point to things like the model
is modelers meaning the people building
these these large simulation models
don't have a software engineering
background their code is very long-lived
it lives for decades and they keep
tinkering with it for decades it's
highly optimized typically for
high-performance machines and these
people resist software engineering tools
they their experience in the past of
software engineers coming in and saying
oh you should be using you should be
using our IDEs or you should be using
these various different tools they find
that they're not well suited to their
context and they very quickly get fed up
of software engineers coming in trying
to tell them what to do so there's this
immediate suspicion so when I first made
contact with this particular group there
was this initial yeah what are you going
to tell us that we don't already know
and when I started to explain that what
I wanted to do was not tell them how to
build software but learn how they
currently build it built it then we got
over that initial hurdle and it said
yeah we'd love you to come in and and
see what we do the code of course is
nearly all written in Fortran and
there's no way they're going to change
that in the foreseeable future Fortran
is highly tailored for what they need
for two reasons one is they have the
experience the entire community knows
Fortran and doesn't know other languages
and the other is that that Fortran is
probably the best suited to what they do
which is they take the scientific
formulas convert them into code and run
them on on high-performance machines
it's hard to imagine a language that's
better suited to that right now so they
prefer to build their own tools rather
than use anybody else's and they have
this worried that because they know any
tool that they adopt they're going to be
using it
decades they have this worried that if
they buy it off a vendor the vendor will
disappear after a few years and it will
be unsupported and and that leaves them
them with a problem so going into the
study I had this naive idea that their
process is climate scientist has some
model in there some scientific theory in
their head that they need to get into
code and run a simulation to produce
some results and that's their scientific
process and that there are two key
things along this path that could get in
the way of their productivity one of
them is is the high performance
computing question how do we get the
most juice out of our hardware how do we
get the simulations to run fast and the
other is the software engineering
question how do we build code that we
can trust as quickly as possible and 11
observations been made of computational
scientists is that they're spending ever
more time on the software engineering
question getting to working code and
because of that they're not able to take
advantage of Moore's law so they're not
getting the improvement in scientific
productivity that you'd expect from
faster machines because they're being
slowed down by how long it takes them to
build the code so which means there's
this there's this gradual shift in I
mean it's been tons and tons of work in
high-performance computing and this is
gradual shift to say actually that's not
now the bottleneck the bottleneck is the
software engineering part and we haven't
spent anywhere near enough time doing
that so that that's some of the
background to the study if I'm if I'm
going to ask eventually about software
quality then I have to worry about a
frame of reference for that question
what does quality mean to this community
and you're going to ask climate
scientists about software quality and
they immediately do a mental translation
in your head to the term that they
usually uses model skill so how well is
the model simulating something about the
real world that they're interested in
they don't talk about
quality they talk about the number of
bugs defects anything like that they
talk about skill and to them that's what
quality means and so that means they
don't ask questions about scientific
productivity are you know is is our our
code practices slowing us down they
don't ask questions about
understandability the code can other
scientists understand what we built and
modify it they don't ask questions about
reliability and all they do ask
questions about portability because
portability nearly always trips them up
every time they upgrade to a new
supercomputer which happens every five
or six years they spend every everything
in the lab stops for six months while
they put the code to the new
architecture they they worry a little
bit about usability but they don't do
anything about it these models are held
to configure and run I tried it and I
couldn't do it if we've got time later
on I'll show you the user interface for
a model configuration so I want to
define quality then as fitness for
purpose which is my favorite definition
of software quality fitness for purpose
for this community means how good is it
as a scientific instrument and the
interesting thing here is quite often
the utility of a model does not depend
on how faithful faithfully it captures
something about the real world so
climate scientists are building
simulations of the climate but quite
often what they want out of a model is
not an accurate simulation of a real
climate they want the ability to ask an
interesting question so I was talking
just before we started with a couple of
you one of the things they'll do is
they'll take a climate model and they'll
remove all the continents so we have an
ocean world and they'll play without and
click quite clearly that does not
represent a real world scenario but it's
an interesting and useful scientific
instrument it allows them to ask
questions that they wouldn't otherwise
being able to ask so quality doesn't
always mean is it a good simulation of
the world it means is it a good tool for
checking my understanding of how the
physical processes work in the world so
this so that assumption of course is is
just built deeply in their culture they
know their mod
are wrong they met they know these
models are inaccurate simulations of a
very very complex physical process and
everything they do is based on that
knowledge so the other thing I should
say is is for the study that I did how I
approached the idea of software quality
and there are essentially four different
ways of measuring quality I think this
is set out very well in Andreas's book I
think this is where this slide
originally came from although you didn't
have the the pictures most of what I
focused on his process quality because
that was what was observable of these
people I went in and looked at their
processes and said how well do they
match what we think we know about good
software processes and where do they
differ where they doing things different
from what the literature says should be
a good software process I also spend a
little bit of time looking at quality in
use when they try and use the models
what happens and I didn't spend much
time on the other two one of my grad
students is doing a follow-up study
running static analyzers over some of
these climate codes and and trying to
correlate observations or software
defects with with what we've seen in the
process quality and the quality in use
and that's a fascinating Fulop study
r-mich net briefly at the end so i
started my study with five initial
questions what do they understand by
correctness which then boils down to how
do they know they can trust their code
how do they ensure reproducibility
because if they're running scientific
experiments on this code how do they
repeat an experiment how does a large
community of scientists engage in
building these codes develop a shared
understanding such that they can
coordinate their activities how do they
prioritize the work how do they figure
out what to do next and how do they do
bug the code so those were my guiding
questions but I should also point out
they approached the study as an
ethnography as me going in as a stranger
as someone that's not familiar with this
domain looking for things that were
surprising to me and many of the things
i looked at we're not surprising to them
at all they said well of course that's
what we do so I one of my guiding
principles was
prize to me as an outsider and so many
of the things that I'll remark upon were
things that I found strange and other
people might not find them strange so
there's a lot of my bias in there as
you'd expect in an ethnographic study so
before I show you what I saw happening I
should just explain what this software
is that these people build so this is a
little detour which could be arbitrary
long depending on how interested you are
in it of what this code is sorry I
shouldn't go there quite yet so first of
all it's very important to understand
that our knowledge of climate change the
basic knowledge of climate change does
not derive from these models they build
it derives from the basic physical
properties of greenhouse gases which
were all known in the 1800's so all the
basic properties of greenhouse gases
will worked out experimentally in the
1800's the first calculation of of
climate sensitivity which in physical
terms it boils down to the question of
if you double the concentration of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere how
much temperature rise do you get that
was all worked out in the 1890s using
pencil and paper from the basic physical
equations ok so it worked out from first
principles so we knew and the number
they got back then which was about 3
degrees centigrade is is consistent with
what the very latest IPCC IPCC forecasts
say it's within the range of the error
so that's been known for well over 100
years so our basic understanding of what
the burning of fossil fuels an emission
of greenhouse gases does to the climate
does not depend upon these simulations
okay so so why do we need models well
what we need models then is to pin down
our understanding to some extent of the
consequences and to make sure that we do
understand the physical processes in
particular we understand what happens at
different time scales so although I can
calculate what the temperature rises for
a ser doubling of co2 I don't know what
time frame that will occur because
there's a lag so how long is the lag how
long
take looking at wrong long term trends
and looking at the regional impacts
because that three degrees temperature
rise does not happen universally across
the globe so where does it happen the
the poles experience about twice as much
temperature differential as equatorial
zones so that the temperature changes
happen differentially across the globe
so that's what we can we can use the
models to to understand and to separate
out different causes to separate out a
number of different forcings that are
changing the climate and start to figure
out which ones are them are having the
biggest effect so one of the things you
can do in the model is turn off things I
mean in in the worst case you turn off
the Sun and see what happens but you can
turn off other things you can turn off
humans you can turn off human emissions
you can turn off all sorts of things in
the model and look at the differences
and just play with them of course what
the what the policymakers want are these
last two things they want to understand
strategies for mitigation for reducing
carbon emissions and adaptation to
changing climates you know where are we
going to get flooding where we going to
get sea level rise what what is what
infrastructure changes are needed and
what policies should be putting it in
place and now we've got a huge tension
because the climate scientists are
comfortable with the stuff at the top
the policymakers are demanding the stuff
at the bottom and the scientists would
rather not run their models in a
predictive mode they would they would
prefer never to have to project forward
and say here's what's going to happen
over the next century they would prefer
to play around with poking and prodding
their models within observational data
sets that we have from the past and
checking their understanding so to them
the model is to check our understanding
of some physical process it's not to
make predictions for the future because
making a prediction for the future even
20 years out to a scientist is useless
you have to wait 20 years to find out if
you were right and by then that's not a
publishable result anymore so so those
kinds of predictions aren't what they do
and hanging out at the lab and listening
to them talking they were just getting
ready for the next round
and of IPC see reporting we're IPCC's
sets a whole bunch of simulation runs
that they would like to have to put
together the report and the scientists
are sitting there saying how can we get
these done as quickly as possible so we
can get back to doing science and that's
their that's their philosophy we want to
get back to doing the science we don't
want to hand the policymakers the stuff
they want and if we do let's let's make
that as as quick and simple as possible
so here's the core idea of what a
climate model is this is a very very
simple model you just add up energy as
it moves around the planet so what's the
total energy in coming from the Sun what
gets reflected by various surfaces
reflected by the the surface reflected
by the clouds what gets absorbed by
gases when does that get released again
where does it get released so it's how
does energy move around in the system
and when i said the initial numbers for
climate sensitivity will worked out in
the 1890s this was basically the
equations they were playing with what's
the energy balance of the earth and
what's the new temperature that you have
to get to to make sure all the energies
are in balance if you change the
composition of the atmosphere now of
course that's a very very simplistic
model and what you really want is a
whole bunch of other feedbacks in there
for example feedback swear if you melt
the ice at the poles that changes the
albedo that that makes that replaces
white ice which reflects sunlight with
dark sea water which absorbs sunlight so
well how does that play into the system
if you melt the permafrost that releases
methane how does that and methane is a
very potent greenhouse gas how does that
play into the system if we change land
uses if we if we start planting new
trees everywhere how does that play into
the system if we cut down trees and so
on how do volcanoes volcanic eruptions
perturb the system so these are the
stuff that the scientists want to play
with they want to play with all these
interesting feedbacks put those into the
simulations and see what happens so the
core of the model is the earth divided
up into two cubes so they take the
atmosphere and divide it into a huge
number of cubes and take the ocean and
divide it into each into a number of
cubes
for each cube at each time step in the
simulation you solve the equations of
fluid motion and that that's it that's
basically what a climate model is now of
course then you have to put all sorts of
interesting boundary effects in there
you have to tell this model where the
where the land masses are where the
mountains are where there are different
kinds of vegetation where there are
sources of greenhouse gases and and and
so there are all sorts of parameters
that you have to add the model to make
it more and more realistic simulation of
the earth but the core essentially is
this huge big computation of fluid flow
and here's an interesting observation in
the last 20 or so years there has been
essentially no change in how long it
takes to do a run of a climate
simulation and yet well wait a minute
wasn't the Moore's law don't we get a
doubling of processing power every
whatever it is 18 months which which is
a dramatic improvement in processing
power over 20 years and yet it still
takes the same amount of time to do a
climate run what happens is every time
they get a faster machine they just
increase the resolution they increase
the the resolution of the grid so the
driving constraint over how long a
climate simulation takes there's only
two constraints really it's how patient
a scientist is is willing to wait for a
result and how much time can they get on
the the local supercomputer to run their
experiment and that's it and the more
time that they have available well well
just up the resolution of the model
because resolution is everything to this
community so this gives you some sense
for for some recent models of the size
of the grid squares so had cm3 which was
the Met Office's main model about seven
or eight years ago and the one that went
into the last round of IPCC reports had
grid squares of forgotten what those are
270 kilometers on a side and nineteen
levels in the atmosphere had Jim Wong
which is its replacement has where are
we 38 levels in the atmosphere and grid
squares 135 kilometers there's a newer
generation of models further map that
goes up to 78 levels in the atmosphere
and the grid squares are getting smaller
and smaller but that's the kind of
resolutions they're playing
so you take your climate model you stick
it on the supercomputers and you set
them running and it'll take typically
got some numbers here about 30 minutes
of CPU time to simulate one day of
climate which means if you multiply that
up a century so say you're interested in
simulating the entire 20th century
that's about 50 days that you have to
run that simulation for on the you know
some of the fastest machines in the
world and here's what you get so this is
what I was showing at the beginning and
I'm just going to quickly for those that
weren't here at the beginning just show
this run because I find it beautiful and
fascinating this is a visualization of
one month in August of climate showing
basically precipitation so this just
shows you where it was raining so anyway
that's white is light rain anywhere it's
oranges heavy rain and the importance of
showing this is to understand that what
falls out of these mother said they're
basically solving fluid fluid flow you
see real weather patterns emerging you
see tropical cyclones in in Japan you
see the the North Atlantic Current
blowing the rain onto the UK you see the
the Indian monsoon occurring and none of
that is programmed into the model this
is all emergent properties of those
basic physical equations for how heat
and energy and water and mass are
transported around the planet according
to where the land masses are what
gravity does and so on and as soon as
you and soon as you see this you say
this is this is what convinces me that
these climate models are incredible
scientific instruments because they can
simulate this isn't a root this isn't
real observational data but it behaves
in the same way that the real climate
system behaves such that when we play
with the model we can believe that this
is as good as as it gets to doing real
experiments on a planet wide scale
of course is what we can't do so let me
stop that and carry on so climate is a
very complex system there's all sorts of
sources of uncertainty there's
measurement error or observational data
that we're testing the moderns against
is has errors in it there's variability
in the physical processes so although
we're studying for example global
warming and superimposed on that warming
are all sorts of other cycles that
completely swamp the warming so the
short-term cycles the the annual and
decadal cycles are much stronger than
the warming signal so you've got to kind
of pick out the signal from the noise
and then there of course model
imperfections the models are imperfect
you cannot simulate everything that you
want to simulate and have it run in a
reasonable amount of time so there's all
sorts of imperfections in the models and
just give you an example of some of the
trade-offs they have to make there are a
huge number of physical processes that
we might want to put into a simulation
and this this graph shows you some of
them things and of course they happen on
different spatial scales so this is a
logarithmic scale from the millimeters
up to where are we hundreds of thousands
of kilometers and from microseconds up
to tens of thousands of years so for
example things like surface gravity
waves turbulent mixing and so on cloud
formation we're interested in in fine
grains of scales climate changes on a
completely different scale El Nino
seasonal cycles and so on so if you're
going to do a particular run for a
particular scientific experiment you've
got to decide which of these things
matter and therefore which physical
processes you want to put into the model
in which you want to leave out because
you can't ever put them all in so
they're continually making these
engineering trade-offs for each
experiment which things do I want in the
model for this experiment and which
don't I want knowing that everything
that you leave out effectively means the
model is less perfect okay so that's the
that's the the context
let's look at how they build the
software so the UK Met Office is one of
the world's leading centers for climate
modeling there are about 25 labs around
the world that build these simulations
each one has their own model and by the
way all the moderns are basically built
at government labs they're not built in
universities they built it government
labs by government scientists because
universities just don't have the
resources to do this so the Met Office
they have a shared code base with lots
of different models they call it the
unified model it's a huge hunk of
Fortran it peaked last year at about a
million lines so million lines of code
I've got some pictures later on to show
you how it's grown and that unified code
base is used to build both weather
forecasting models nwp is numerical
weather prediction so the Met Office in
the UK is an operational weather
forecasting center in fact they provide
weather forecasting services for about
half the planet for civil aviation for
military operations for the media for
all sorts of commercial outlets there
are they are an operational weather
forecasting center and they out of the
same code base they build the climate
models so a lot of the core routines a
lot of numerical routines are the same
in a weather forecasting model and a
climate model what's different is the
scales at which they're looking at
things they have this very I call it a
hybrid development process it's very
much bottom-up the scientists themselves
decide what's important to work on and
what they want to add to the model but
they also have some top-down management
priorities to say there are some
scientific priorities there are from the
operational forecasting side of the
house certain certain business goals
they're trying to satisfy and those are
superimposed upon this community of
scientists who are sitting there saying
here's what I want to do with the code
and nearly everything they build is in
house except they're starting to engage
a little bit in the idea of a community
model so this is a community of
scientists across the world or in some
cases across a particular country who
are working together to build a
particular module
so one example of that for example is
the UK atmospheric chemistry group who
have built a model of atmospheric
chemistry and they're trying to
incorporate that into the Met Office's
model so that's code from outside the
lab being incorporated so the Met Office
has about 50 different software
development projects in house at the
moment of those the unified model which
is their core simulation world lets the
biggest project they have going it's
currently I said it peaked at about a
million it's down to about 850 source
lines of code of that nearly a third has
changed in the last two years so the
amount of code churn here is phenomenal
in on the climate side of the house
there's about 170 scientists on the
weather prediction side of the house is
about 300 scientists scientists with
background in meteorology numerical
analysis climate ology and you know apps
for chemistry oceanography a few other
things and supported by small teams of
IT specialists and I'll talk about their
role in a few minutes all of the code is
built by the scientists so virtually
every line of code originated from one
of those scientists with each release
they do a new release of the model about
every four months each release has about
a hundred people who have contributed
code to that particular release so
here's my graph of the code growth the
the green line is lines of code lines of
Fortran on this scale here so you can
see a million at the top there and
that's where it peaked with version 6.6
the blue line is the number of files on
the right hand scale so about 3,000
modules currently and what's interesting
about this curve here to me is I said I
was looking for things that surprise me
it's approximately linear over a 15-year
period of the I can't get records back
older than 15 years I trawled through
their archives and so over a 15-year
period they've seen an approximately
linear steady growth of that code base
with those two little perturbations here
and those are easily explained
you can ask them what happened here they
stripped out the dynamical core of the
model the basic core numerical methods
were considered old-fashioned they
stripped them out replaced them with a
new core and of course that basically
stopped all other work in the lab for
nearly a year while they got those
working and in hindsight they say we
tried to change too many things at once
and so when we are up again for a place
in the core we won't do it all at once
again so that was that glitch there it
took them till version 5.1 to get
everything working again and this little
glitch here they stripped out the old
ocean model they were using an ocean
model from gfdl in Princeton and they
threw that away and used a new ocean
model from a group in Paris and the new
ocean models a lot more compact so you
get a drop in code there so apart from
those two glitches it's a linear growth
over a long period of time what's
driving that change I said it was very
bottom up here's what happens there is
the the three colored blobs are
basically the three drivers of change to
this code base so one is physics
research so new insights new data and
new papers published about the physical
properties that they're trying to
simulate in the model so they're
incorporating new research into the
model and the other two blobs are day
after day after day after day running
the models comparing them with
observational data sets comparing them
with other people's models and feeding
back improvements into the models so
both the weather prediction side of the
house and the climate modeling outside
of the house are doing this every day in
fact that's where most of the changes
come from they come from this
continually running the model playing
with it and trying to improve it those
I've drawn these smaller there's there's
an occasional attempt to clean up the
code actually it's not to scale it
should be a tiny little cloud you
probably wouldn't even see it on my
slide if I drew this to scale there is
very little code cleanup goes on and
there's some good reasons for that one
is I talked about reproducibility before
the ability to reproduce an experiment
if you clean up the code and you mess
around with exactly what phenomena
emerged from the model when you run it
over a long period of time you've broken
the ability to run an old experiment
again
they have this constraint and i'll talk
about it a little bit more later known
as bit reproducibility so every change
that you make to the model should
preserve bit reproducibility what that
means is you run the old model you run
the new model and the outputs should be
identical down to the most significant
bit and of course these are all real
numbered variables we're playing with so
down to the most significant bit in a
double precision real number simulations
have to be identical if you break that
that's a big thing there's this list on
their website of changes that break bit
reproducibility and they'll spend ages
tracking down to them to set to say can
we get rid of that now there's two
reasons why bit reproducibility matters
one is because you want to rerun an
experiment and get exactly the same
results again but the other is that bit
reproducibility gives them a free ride
when it comes to testing so if you think
it if it takes a month to run a
century's worth of climate simulation
that means testing this thing is hell
you have to wait a month for your test
so what they do instead is they'll run
it for let's say one day of simulation
or even one hour of simulation and if
down at the very least significant bit
it's identical that's a good indicator
that if they let it run for the whole
century they'd get the same result it's
not guaranteed but it's a damn good
proxy for letting it run for the whole
month and so they can run a very large
number of experiments overnight unit
tests for example test bit
reproducibility and if none of the bit
reproducibility tests are broken that's
a good indication that nothing did get
broken good question yes yeah so when it
comes to something like testing when
you've been saying the model there isn't
one model hmm young family or related
yowls depending on what yep parameters
you use or whatever so how do they know
even if they preserved one they have
others okay I'll answer that I think in
the next few slides and if I don't ask
the question again because it's
important so some of these some of the
requirements for this model conflict for
example from the weather forecasting
side of the house the simulations must
be very fast and give accurate forecasts
and in fact they have a very precise set
of metrics forecast accuracy and a
business goal of improving accuracy by a
certain percentage every year so
accurate forecasts are the most
important thing for those people for the
climate scientists scientific validity
is more important they will accept a run
that's less faithful to the
observational data set as long as it's
better physics so of course what you get
is the weather forecasting people are
always tweaking the modeler was trying
to tune it to give very very good
simulations of current weather
situations the climate modelers would
refer didn't get tuned quite that much
so much they don't care so much about
faithfulness they care about is the
physics in the model defensible is this
our understanding of what's happening
there's also tensions between components
in the model that have different origins
so the stuff that's developed in-house
which is most of the code is very
tightly controlled the stuff that's
contributed from outside is a real
problem for them it can take a good six
months worth of work by several people
to take an external chunk of code and
integrate it with this model get it to
work on on their in-house platform so
naturalizing external code is a big
problem for them and they prefer that
didn't happen but that's the way it is
so their basic tool set is everything is
all the code is controlled through
subversion everybody works on a branch
they use track as their bug tracker
they've got a graphical code diff that
they use quite a lot for for playing
around with differences they've built a
custom user interface to subversion and
track to greatly simplify the
don't have to know really much about how
subversion works there's only two or
three subversion commands they ever use
and they've simplified the interface to
those so the scientists don't have to
understand subversion that will they've
got a custom build and a custom code
extract system that went will want to
build a particular operational model it
goes and gets all the physical schemes
that have been chosen into that model
does the build automatically sends it to
the supercomputer and starts the run so
all of that is is at a push of a button
so coordinating coordinating these big
teams is a big challenge so they're all
working on branches and subversion so
here's how it works essentially each of
the operational models and there's about
eight or nine operational models in
house built from this code base each is
a separate branch in the subversion
repository each has its own release no
sorry at their back yes reh is on a
branch in the room subversion repository
and has its own release schedule and the
core code base itself the unified model
has its own release schedule you saw on
my graph of codes each of the dotted
lines was an official release one of the
big problems they have is how often
should they update their branch from
other changes how often should i
incorporate changes that other people
doing into the branch I'm working on if
you do it too often then you know you
have to stop what you're doing and spend
spend time getting everything working
again if you use it to really you get
too big an increment and everything
breaks and just being aware of what
changes are happening elsewhere in the
lab across a team of several hundred
scientists it's impossible to know what
other people are working on and yet they
desperately need to know so they have a
very heavy reliance on informal
communications so they solve most of
their problems just by knowing who to go
and talk to and the interesting thing is
these several hundred scientists they're
essentially in one big open plan office
they occupy the entire floor of the
building and you can get pretty much
from any desk to any other without
passing through any door or staircase it
is a huge big open plan office and they
all say that's important to them about
five years ago
six years ago they moved to a new site
in a different town and previously there
were the numerical weather prediction
and the climate research were in
different buildings with a car park in
between and they will say oh it's much
better now we don't have to walk across
the car park so that's clearly important
to them oh yes I mentioned that they use
extensive use of wikis and newsgroups
within the lab to keep informed of
what's going on lots of email the other
thing they do a lot is they form
temporary cross-functional teams so
they've got a particular phenomena going
on in the model and the one that I saw
when I was there is a big problem where
the Indian monsoon is too dry so they
put together a team made up of different
scientists from different disciplines
across the lab who will get together
regularly over a six-month period and
figure out what they need to do to fix
this and this is one of the ways that
they learn who else is in the lab and
what they know by participating in these
teams on a regular basis they all get to
know who else is there and what other
people know so that's how they maintain
the social network they also are
organized a little bit like a typical
open source project with you've seen
studies of open source they'll talk
about the onion model where you have a
project leader and then you have a core
set of members who decide what goes into
a release and then larger groups of code
contributors who are less heavily
engaged in the team other people who are
just users people who report bugs and so
on so there's impassive users so there's
a core set of people here who control
the project and you don't get to be in
the core until you've proven yourself
it's a meritocracy so the chord changes
relatively slowly and only people only
accept it into the core of an
open-source community when they've
proven that they can they've got what it
takes well that's how these guys
organize themselves they've got at the
core they have those systems teams and
the systems teams look after the
releases so they'll plan a release on
about a four month schedule and they'll
take code contributions from scientists
any way across the lab to say you can
you can submit your change to this
upcoming release but it has to be ready
by a certain date
there's a cut off about a month before
the expected release where they they
they freeze the code actually they talk
about a frosting rather than freezing
because they still allow some changes
and from that point on the system's team
here work like crazy taking no more than
three changes each day incorporating
them into the trunk running the
overnight test harness and if everything
worked then they move on to the next set
of changes for the next day and then
outside of them are a set of kono koe
donors so there's about 20 senior
scientists across the lab each one
assigned a particular chunk of code that
they are the expert and they have to
approve all changes to that chunk of
code and they they have two stages a
review before the change is actually
made there at wrigley if there's a large
change they have to approve this is even
a reasonable thing to be working on and
then once it's ready they have to
approve that it's now ok to accept into
an upcoming release they also have this
I've drawn it kind of slim they have
this set of configuration managers 1 /
operational model so this is a typically
a scientist who ends up spending about
fifty percent of their time not doing
science but worrying about how changes
are affecting one of those operational
models so this is the answer to your
question they have these designated
people whose job it is to look after a
particular configuration of the model
and then they have a set as i said in
any particular reason undred people who
are contributing code to that release a
large number of scientists is end users
and and i didn't draw it's another ring
here another group of people who are
preparing changes for future releases
who are just playing around with stuff
if you look at the repository you can
see exactly what i described here these
are the top where are we however many
changes to the trunk of the UM over some
period of time are coming with the time
period is so there's only 14 people that
contributed code to the trunk and here's
notice this you can you if you know what
the user names are the top one two three
four five six seven all their user names
start with Fr that's the system's team
for the weather prediction side of the
house the the for username starting here
with had are the system's team for the
climate modeling side of the house
basically the only people putting code
into the trunk other systems team but
they didn't write that code that code
all came from scientists who are
contributing code for upcoming releases
and notice the the the weather
prediction people completely dominate
the the climate change people in terms
of numbers of code and amount of code
that's being changed so how do they do V
and V in this environment lots of
informal desk desk checking they don't
have any formal unit testing process
there's no requirement to do unit
testing and most of them just don't
bother there is these two stages of
review that I mentioned but here's where
nearly all the V and V comes it's a
continuous testing set up as science
experiments I talked about bit
reproducibility and I talked about the
automated overnight test harness on the
main trunk so this one here is the one I
haven't talked about yet and this is the
one that I find deeply fascinating and
unusual so here's what you do if you're
making a change to your branch you set
your change up as a science experiment
you've got a hypothesis that you're
testing if i change this little bit of
code here i think i can make an
improvement to the model that will have
the following effect and then you test
that hypothesis by running the new code
using an old run of the model just
before you changed it as your control so
now I've got a scientific experiment
with to the two treatments the control
and the and the new code and your
observational data as your measurement
of how well you did and you push a
button when you submit the code you push
a button and it generates all these
visualizations of the results so what
you see here is for a different model
parameter and this by the way this is
just the top portion of a wiki page that
that goes on there's about 30 different
parameters that they've picked out here
that they want to see visualizations of
and each one is a 4 up display and I
should explain what the four up display
is so you see four different
visualizations of this one model
variable the first is so in this case
what they're doing is they're
experimenting with a new polar filter
the Antarctic so something that's
supposed to improve sea surface
temperatures over the Antarctic so this
is pmsl which is mean pressure at sea
level for djf december january and
February's so the Winter Court winter in
the Northern Hemisphere winter quarter
of the year that's the raw result from
the new from the new model from the
changed code this is the difference this
is the Delta between the control the old
version of the code and the new version
of the code so this is now where in the
world did we make a difference and the
differences or where they're expected to
be there around the Antarctic the
biggest difference is there but this is
whole band where the differences are
where they're supposed to be that's good
this one here is the control minus the
observational data set so this is how
well was the old model simulating an
observed data for this period so these
are anomalies this is where anywhere
that's darkly shaded here this is where
the model was doing badly before this is
the new code minus the observational
data set so this is how badly the new
model doing and there's less dark blue
and there's less dark blue weather's
supposed to be less dark blue so this
was a successful experiment and by the
way success here is done by eyeballing
these graphs that that's that's the
criteria so since they look at them and
they stare at them and they they pass
that I set in these meetings where
they've walked in with their latest
pictures like this and they sit down and
there's not a word of explanation
there's a four or five people in the
room handed these grasses the first time
they're seeing them and they say oh yeah
you did it you got you got what you were
looking for and they just go straight in
nobody has to explain what they're
seeing okay because these visualizations
are there their common currency this is
what they spend all their time staring
at they also some of them this is not a
universal practice across the lab but
some of them use their wikis as as
electronic lab notebooks so this is one
of those configuration managers who's
keeping track of every experiment so
every five letter acronym here is an
experiment it was a change to the code
where one of those experiments was run
comparing the the old versus the new and
he in the middle here he's written down
what a brief few words summary of what
change was and noticed that he's got
several different models he's trying it
in so n96 l38 is a particular resolution
of the model with 38 levels in the
atmosphere and I forget what 96 means in
terms of horizontal resolution but a
particular resentful resolution in 96
l70 is a higher resolution model and n1
44 l 30 8 is another different
resolution so some of his experiments
are in one resolution model summer in
another one one of the things you'll do
is he'll try it out in one model if that
works he'll try it out of the different
model so again in answer to your
question he's going around
systematically looking does the change
work first of all in one model and then
how does it affect models at different
resolutions with difficult different
physical properties I think everything
in red here was an experiment that
failed I better go back and check this I
think everything that's in black was a
successful experiment everything was in
red it failed it didn't do what it's
supposed to do and the one that's in
green I haven't figured out only ways
anyway and then every single one of
those experiments course the reason
they're there blue is that they're
they're hyperlinks in the wiki leads to
a lab notebook for that experiment who
did it what it was what it was supposed
to show links to the visualizations of
the output a brief description of the
results and so on so he's got electronic
record of every experiment here's
another visualization that they commonly
use for getting a bigger picture of how
well they're doing as they're improving
the model so this graph here summarizes
there's about 30 or more than 30 core
indicators of model skill each one
typically expressed as a root mean
squared error over an observational data
set so when you get down to zero you
match the observational data perfectly
and what they've done is they've taken
all of those variables and normalize
them so that for each variable one is
where the old model was so that line
there is this is what the old model did
the colored dots are what the new model
did so you've got a one-shot
visualization of where are we getting
worse and where are we getting better if
you're above the line you're doing worse
you below the line you're doing better
and the whiskers are the error range in
the observational data so if you're
within the whisker you're now within
your target of where you want to be so
everything in the new model that's
within within the observational whisker
is green that's that's good we've got
where we want to be for those variables
everything that's red is a variable
we're doing worse on than the old model
everything that's amber is where we're
doing better than the old model but we
still haven't met our target range
against the observational data they also
spend a lot of time doing model into
comparisons so comparing their models on
standard scenarios with other people
around the world and there's a huge
amount of effort goes into this they'll
also do model ensembles they'll take
large numbers of different models and
run them over and over and over again to
do probabilistic forecasts and that's
how a lot of the forecasting when they
do forecasting that's how it's done so
let me try and that that's what goes on
in this lab let me try and summarize
some of what's happening first of all an
observation that actually I found
surprising after trolling through the
literature this approximately linear
growth in their code is unusual over
such a sustained period of time if you
go and look in the literature of people
have done these long-term studies of
code growth and the classic ones were
all done by lemon on commercial systems
he points out that all the commercial
systems he studied have this
approximately inverse square curve as
the code grows but as it grows it gets
bigger growth tails off because of the
growth of complexity it just gets harder
and harder to change the model as it
gets bigger will change the code as it
gets bigger so somehow these scientists
have escaped from that trap studies of
open source this is from mike godfrey
study of the linux kernel do tend to
have this linear growth that he showed
that the kernel itself is approximately
linear over some long period of time and
it's superlinear if you take into
account all the device drivers that are
being added well let's leave out device
drivers that just complicates the
it's approximately linear if you just
look at the kernel itself yeah still how
many projects in the world would you say
there are with more than a million lines
of code is this ever I just a very
common now that's a girl x 10 in the
whole world but that's a great question
I don't know anybody else know as I said
that was quite exciting that in the
context software in you yeah okay I know
it's big but I don't know how many other
projects it compares that's a very good
question right so so one observation
here is that it appears to have escaped
a trap that lots of commercial code
falls into that growth tails off after a
while because of the complexity and so
now I have to explain that if it's more
like open source than its casing is what
is it what's common about open source
projects some open source projects and
this scientific code that's different
from commercial systems and my best
hypothesis for that right now is the
domain experts are writing the code and
it might just be as simple as that in
most commercial systems the domain it's
but as I say you're building financial
software the domain experts don't write
code they have to explain to the
programmers what's needed and then
there's this big communication gap so
one hypothesis is that in a lot of open
source and a lot of the scientific code
you don't get that communication gap so
you escaped the complexity trap I don't
know it's a hypothesis that needs
testing we have nowhere near enough data
on code growth in different types of
projects that so there are just aren't
enough data points to be to be sure even
that the phenomena that lemon pointed
out is really true what about defect
rates I attempted to do a
back-of-the-envelope calculation of
their defect density comparing to some
stuff that's been described in the
literature so NASA Space Shuttle is
usually held up in the literature as as
the best ever and the most expensive per
line of code ever built in the world and
they report about point one failure per
thousand lines of code post-release well
in the unified model let's say I take
the last six releases over the last six
releases the average is about 2400
Ashley's very small variability it sits
somewhere between 20 and
30 bugs / release with an average of 24
and an average of 50 thousand lines
edited / release so what does that mean
that means about two defects per
thousand lines of code are making it
through their release process undetected
or if I expend that to an expected
defect density of the entire code base I
get a number naught point naught three
faults per thousand lines of code in
that code base right now now of course
this depends on what you count as a bug
you know how did I count defects while I
counted what was reported as errors in
their bug tracking system do they record
all areas in bug tracking systems the
same way that NASA would or in military
systems would or Microsoft would okay
I've got my grad student doing a
follow-up study on this to try and get
better numbers because first of all
we're not sure if this is believable if
it is believable it's remarkable so
first of all we better check that these
numbers actually are even within orders
of magnitude anywhere near accurate and
they appear to be and so the next
question is well how to explain that how
do I explain this relatively low defect
density compared to other types of
software and you know we've played
around with why don't they seem to have
many errors well in in large scale
numerical simulations most of the era
most of the coding errors that you could
make will be instantly obvious for a
certain number reasons first of all the
model just won't run or secondly it does
run but it crashes pretty soon because
some variables just gone out of range
and the simulation is just gone haywire
and you only have to run it once to spot
that and of course they're running every
change lots and lots of times and then
they've got these these bit comparison
tests to make sure that you didn't break
anything so it's a very very
conservative change process that doesn't
let many bugs into the released code and
then we'd spent a little bit of time
probing some of the bugs that did make
it into the release code to find out
what happened and let me tell you one
story which which I found fascinating
there was an error that had been in the
code for a couple of years in the in the
released versions of the um before it
was fixed and it was an error in the
soil hydrology module so how much
moisture is there in the soil which of
course affects how much moisture is
being passed into plants which affects
the evaporation of moisture into the
atmosphere which affects where the water
is in the system the reason the code the
error was in the code was because the
routine in this soil hydrology module
was taken from a published paper that
had done a study of soil hydrology and
they'd got some some parameters from
this published paper and a couple of
equations from the published paper in
this in this code and they'd mistakenly
taken a logarithm in the paper and
assumed it was a natural logarithm when
it was actually a log to base 10 so they
were off by what's the conversion factor
to point something in this equation and
so the soil was kind of men which way it
is now is too dry and they'd been aware
that they were having problems with
moisture in the model around the soil
and plant evaporation for a period of
time so they kind of knew that something
wasn't right and they just didn't have
time to fix it it wasn't causing a big
enough change in the moisture elsewhere
in the model that it became urgent to
fix so for two years they kind of knew
something was wrong but they didn't know
what and they just to nap tune that out
they say well just add some extra tuning
into the model to compensate for that
problem we know it's there one day we'll
get around to fixing it but we can run
all our science experiments without
fixing it because we've got all sorts of
other inaccuracies in the model and so
it doesn't matter and then one day a
scientist in the lab had a bit of spare
time he said I'm going to track that bug
down we're going to find out what
happened and the way he tracked it down
was he went and got five or six other
models from other labs looked at their
soil hydrology modules ran their
simulations and compared those to the
met office's and discovered that in five
out of the six models that he found they
all agreed with the Met Office model but
one model was noticeably different and
so he then tried to track down where the
Prince was and he pinned it down to this
particular equation in the model and lo
and behold the one that was different
had got the right logarithm in the model
and the other five had all got the wrong
logarithm in the model and you know
they'd all talked about this in shared
code and shed and said the error had
propagated across all these different
models so they found it by comparing so
their factory other people around the
world building the same software for
essentially the same purpose gives them
a huge advantage it's not clear i
chatted to hear this guy at length about
how he found the bug and it's not clear
he would ever found it if you didn't
have the ability to go and grab other
people's models and compare them okay so
that allows me to let me let me start to
wrap up and draw some conclusions I
having spent this time at this lab and
looked at what they do I characterize it
as an extremely successful software
development outfit they build very high
quality code they are very careful about
which tools they use but they know that
the tools they use are essential and
they're resistant to trying out other
stuff just because it's fashionable and
they've managed to you know have this
linear growth in code there's no tail
off in in the growth of the
functionality of their code over a very
long period of time so what matters it
matters that they have a highly tailored
software development process they don't
do what the textbooks say you should do
they do what works for them and over a
very large number of years a large group
of very smart people you know they're
all physics phd's they're smart people
and they spend time thinking about how
to make improvements to their process so
over many many years they've tinkered
with the process and they've evolved
something that's highly adapted to their
environment their context not by
listening to the literature but by
playing around with stuff and if it
works they adopted and if it doesn't
work they don't use it the as i said the
coders are the domain experts and that
appears to be crucial they have this
very strong sense of shared ownership so
they're like a small software startup in
many
respects like an agile software
development team they all own this code
and they all feel a very strength strong
sense of ownership and a very strong
sense that we're all responsible for
making sure it works so they have that
that also that idea from open source of
many eyes validation as many people
looking at this code and worrying about
it so the chances are people will look
at the code and find the errors so they
also have this openness you know they're
there the code is it's not officially
open source it's not given away freely
you have to sign a license with them if
you want it they'll give it to any other
research outfit for free if they sign
the license and but pretty much the only
people that use it our in-house there
are a small number of communities
outside the Met Office that run this
model but the biggest group of users are
in-house they do a lot of benchmarking
work these model intercomparison
projects that they spend a lot of time
running simulations over everybody's
different models and comparing them and
oh one thing I didn't mention is they
don't have a fixed release schedule so
although I said they plan a four-month
release cycle they don't decide a
release date until they're ready so they
have a target in mind and the systems
team are running their overnight tests
every day until they've got every change
folded in but they don't announce a
release date pretty much till the day of
the release they say today we're done
we've got all the changes folded in
nothing broke we can announce a release
and they won't release until it is ready
so and because there's no external
customers using this they can do that it
doesn't matter when the release happens
the release matters for stability but it
doesn't matter because there's no one
waiting there to buy it or to upgrade or
anything and people are relatively slow
to upgrade to newer versions of the
model so highly adapted processes they
use all sorts of bits of agile practice
or things that i would call agile
practice they don't use this terminology
at all so the ones that are checked in
green here are things that i think they
use the ones that are in red are the
ones that they don't appear to do
anything like this and the ones in
yellow ones where i couldn't decide they
kind of sort of do it but you know it's
not clear so it's interesting they've
picked
and chosen bits of agile practice that
work for them but they certainly don't
do a deer to any standard agile model
they have a very strong sense of a
shared conceptual architecture they all
know their way around the code they all
know which bit of the code corresponds
to which physical process and they all
got pictures like this in their heads of
what the main units are and how they
interact and then there's all sorts of
interesting comparisons with open source
this release schedule that's not
constrained by commercial pressures
developers being domain experts is again
common of the best open source projects
a core group of code owners who very
tightly control what gets accepted into
the trunk a community that operates as a
meritocracy so the people that are best
able to code do the coding the people
that are best able to look after the
scientific direction of the model look
after the scientific direction of the
model and so on and those groups are
relatively stable and change very rarely
oh and here's my favorite observation
none of the people that write the code
for this model think of themselves as
programmers they're not programmers they
all are scientists doing scientific
research the only reason they ever build
code is because they need it for the
research so it's like an open-source
developer who has a day job but happens
to tinker occasionally with tools
because they want the tools to do
whatever they need in their day job so
they're not programmers their scientists
who just occasionally have to write code
and then the verification validation is
based on extensive use by the developers
themselves challenges let me pick out a
few things where they are having serious
problem i meant mentioned coordination
they do have a big problem with
coordinating changes across all the
different branches in the lab and just
knowing what else is going on and know
who knowing who else is making a change
that somebody ought to fold in with
something that they're doing they really
want to get into multi-site development
the multi-site development thing is
important because these models are now
getting so complex with so many
different scientific modules from
different disciplines like as soon as
you put in plant biology and soil
hydrology
and oceanography and you can't have all
that expertise in one lab anymore you
used to be able to either they're
getting to the point where they just
can't so they want to have multi site
development where some of the modules
are built elsewhere where there's
expertise and import it into this model
and every time they've done that they've
got into huge difficulty there's a there
was a big fight going on in the lab when
I was there last summer over the new
ocean model so the new ocean model is
built by a group in Paris and one of the
things they did with the old ocean water
which came from Princeton about 15 years
ago was basically when they took that
old ocean model and put it into the um
they did a code fork they basically had
to start making their own changes to
make the ocean model work in their in
their code and of course as soon as they
did that they forked from the old ocean
model which means they got a
state-of-the-art ocean model but they
lost the connection with the original
team so they couldn't get all the
updates to it as it as it got steadily
better so they've now got a notion model
that just wasn't keeping up with the
science so when they went to Nemo which
is this new model from Paris they said
we're not going to do that we're not
going to fork we're going to write an
agreement with Paris folks that all the
changes that we need to make the ocean
model work in our model will be folded
into the baseline in Paris and looked
after by the team in Paris and so now
they're going to avoid for King but
they're buying themselves a whole bunch
of other coordination problems because
the team in Paris is basically four
people and they have very strong folks
in Paris have very strong notions about
where they're taking their model in the
future and which changes this should
accept in which they shouldn't and one
of their overriding design principles is
portability they want their ocean model
to work everywhere and everyone's
different hardware with all sorts of
different models the Hadley folks want
it to work very well in the Hadley model
so they're pushing changes on the group
in Paris saying you've got to change
this in your model to make it work on
our architecture and the focus in Paris
is saying we can't make that change
because that breaks portability with
everybody else's models so now they're
getting into all these fists but not
fist fights but they're getting into
these fights over which changes need to
be made to this ocean model and who's
going to be responsible for those
changes without forking
and that's a big problem for them I
think I might wrap up and let me say one
more thing about future challenges and
this crops up in the literature in
climate science quite often there's this
there's this long-standing desire in the
community to build plug-and-play models
to have each of the different physical
modules be plug plug and play you know I
take the ocean model from Paris and just
plug it in and have it work and that
depends upon you know having an
appropriate shared architecture having
well-defined interfaces having couplers
that couple of different physical
routines and do all the scaling across
resolutions at all the boundaries and
all sorts of crazy things that happen to
make these modules work together and for
20 years they've been talking about this
in the literature we're working towards
plug-and-play we're making progress on
the whole plug-and-play thing and I've
sat down with several lead climate
scientists over the last year and said
you know this isn't working out you're
really not making any progress on this
are you what's going on and they've all
said quite frankly it isn't going to
happen and it isn't going to happen
because of the core complexity of the
physics the domain is inherently tightly
coupled and it's tightly coupled in a
way that it is impossible to separate
out the different modules have different
people build them and have them work
together without a hell of a lot of work
so integrating somebody else's ocean
model into your atmospheric model for
example requires lots of deep changes in
both models to make them work and and
they're now saying you know what it's
finally time that we accepted that and
said this notion of a nice modular
architecture just will not work in this
domain the physics of it just won't
allow it now I don't know if that's true
or not and I love a way of validating
that as an observation is it impossible
for them to have the kind of modularity
that we'd expect to see in good software
the physics prevent this we don't know
and
I think that's a great research project
to undertake to find out if this is even
possible let me talk about where next so
there's a couple of things that we're
doing is immediate follow-ups to that
study one is I said one of my grad
students is doing a much more detailed
study of defect density and I'll show
you some of his preliminary results in a
second we want to replicate this study
at other modeling centers to see these
guys unique or do other modeling centers
do it differently there is one ccsm
which is a built a 10-car in but in
Colorado which is actually a community
effort is the only one in the world that
isn't an in-house one site development
team it's a it's a community model and
so I want to go there and find out first
of all is it really a community model
and what we suspect from our initial
conversations with them is it it isn't
at all it's an in-house model in which
there's a core team spending a lot of
time taking code contributions from this
open-source community around North
America and spending ages reimplemented
them to get them into this model we
think that's what's happening but I need
to go and validate that and I want to
compare the V and V that goes on with
these models with other kinds of
simulation models for example economics
models used in climate policy or other
environmental science policies because
we also think that the core approach to
V and V that goes on here is kind of
unique among scientific code and one of
the reasons I think it's unique is
they're leveraging off a huge effort by
tens of thousands of people around the
world collecting meteorological data and
validating that data and it's hard to
think of any other scientific discipline
that has the level of activity going on
in collecting and validating
observational data against which to test
the models it just doesn't happen in
many scientific disciplines so that
matters a lot to them it matters that
they've got huge volumes of
observational data and it matters that a
very large number of people are using
that data for all sorts of things to
validate it and it also matters that
there's lots of teams around the world
simultaneously trying to solve the same
problem that they can all compare
against one another and that again i
think is unusual in scientific
disciplines
so my grad student John pipitone you can
actually see his work he runs a lovely
blog in which he describes his progress
on this he's taken three different
models one of these is the Hadley model
I didn't check which one it is i think
it's the bottom one but anyway it's one
of his item be no yes either b or c
anyway he's measured measured the defect
density of these models by trolling
through their bug databases and the the
the the scale on the bottom here of
defect density to defects per thousand
lines of code this is from norman
fenton's book about code defects where
he classifies anything less than two was
good from two to six as average and then
above that is poor so by those standard
code metrics in the literature all three
of these models are good quality code
from a software defect point of view but
he showed this to several software
engineers to say okay is the code good
quality and they'll say well you know
what these numbers don't actually tell
me anything because it still boils down
to what you call a bug and because of
this attitude these scientists have
which is appropriate for their domain
that many things that might in other
domains be thought of as defects in the
code are just acceptable imperfections
maybe they're just not counting defects
enough he's doing another study with
static analyzers to trawl through to
find static analysis problems in their
fortran and see how that compares and
he's also gone round and interviewed a
whole bunch of climate scientists to
talk about this issue of bug versus
feature when does a bug become a problem
or not and he's teased out lots of
factors factors to do with momentum
stopping to fix this bug will slow down
the science it will break repeatability
it will break a whole bunch of things
we're going to go back and do a whole
bunch of experiments again so we just
accept the imperfection call it a
feature the design the model and funding
issues matter and then operation how the
bug affects various operational factors
matters and these these different
factors come into play at different
points in in the process the you know
whether we're in development stage or a
scientific experimentation stage matter
it matters when the bug was found what
time should I wrap up let me say one
more thing and that is just to put this
study into a broader context so where I
where I started on this was this
question of can we help climate
scientists and the reason i was asking
that question was because i wanted to
ask a broader question of what should
computer scientists in general be doing
in response to this whole issue of
climate change what do we bring to the
table that might help given that this is
a societal grand challenge and having
studied this group and with the
follow-up studies that we're planning to
do we've started to come to the
conclusion that that's not where
computer science as a discipline can
have the biggest impact and let me then
just in two or three slides try to
explain that and then I'll stop and
we'll do questions so here's his the
system ok we have emissions of
greenhouse gases leading to changes in
concentration in the atmosphere which
affect the climate ology of the planet
which have downstream effects on a whole
bunch of other things marine biology
agronomy ecology and so on which caused
a number of impacts from climate change
there's all sorts of change in the
geochemistry which lead to other changes
and the feedback effects and there's all
sorts of physical things going on in a
very very complex coupled system and all
the scientists that I've talked to are
you know they're working in some of
these squares they're working in climate
ology or one of the closely related
disciplines this is very very complex
science what they have to understand are
very very complex physical processes but
nearly all of them say you know what
this science is done we understand the
climate system well enough that this
isn't the important question that
society has to face anymore the
important question is the other part of
the system the part of the system where
impacts lead to changes in public
opinion to discussions in the media
which feed into policy which is affected
by industrial
lobbyists where policy affects what goes
on to in the economy and what's
happening in the economy drives the
emissions and so on and all of these
purple blobs are very poorly understood
it's like this part of the system we
know really well this part of the system
we really haven't a clue about and this
of this part of the system down here is
the stuff that matters this is what we
have to fix because the the argument is
that humanity has stepped in and taken
control of the planet where for millions
of years the planet had a whole bunch of
natural control systems on climate and
natural feedbacks that just clip the
climate stable every so often it flipped
like from a glacial state to a nun
glacial state but pretty much in in any
of those periods it was stable because
of a number of feedbacks that kept this
a stable system we've now perturbed this
system so much that whether we like it
or not humans are now managing the
planet and we don't know how to do it
and the reason we don't know how to do
it is because we're getting all this
stuff down here wrong the discussions in
the media are just ill-informed there
are too many people in jip injecting
misinformation in the media there are
too few people that just don't
understand the physics of what's going
on so they don't understand the urgency
of the problem the time scales in which
we have to do things and so on so our
observation is actually computer science
has a huge role to play down here in
just understanding these systems and
building tools and visualizations to to
make people just aware of what this
system is and how it operates and and
what we know and how we know it from the
various different physical sciences so
our observation was you know computer
scientists have to step up to the plate
and we as a discipline ought to be able
to respond in a systematic way and
saying here's what computer sciences
should do so there's the beautiful
reports I mean this is the IPCC report
on the physical science it's it's a huge
long report and it summarizes everything
we know about the physics of climate
change there's the stern report which is
a beautiful analysis from an economic
point of view there is an APA report on
the psychology of climate change how is
this affecting people's ability to
understand the future to understand how
they're going to adapt their
lives to behavioral changes that have to
happen if we're going to change the way
we live our lives so there's a huge
amount of psychology research has to go
on sociologists to put together a report
saying this is a sociological problem of
how people come to understand like the
social epistemology of climate change
how do people come to understand what
they understand about climate and how
can we have we fix that and so I said
well where's the where's the computer
science version of this whereas
computing as a discipline stepping up to
the plate and saying what should we be
doing and the closest that i could find
was this which i thought was a very
disappointing response so we're starting
to map out what we think is an
appropriate disciplinary response by
computer science as a whole to the
challenge of climate change and we've
we've held a series of workshops there
was a initial work shopper dixie last
year we did a workshop a doob slur in
orlando last month just trying to map
out the agenda and and this is my latest
map of where computer science can make a
difference so the green green IT green
software energy saving devices making
everything that's controlled by software
as energy efficient as possible and
build that into the software the space
that the study are described today fits
into here I kind of Kali
computer-supported collaborative science
how can we help the scientists do what
they do better using good science tools
so II science is the other label for
that box and then this is the box that
that interests me the most maybe I
should put some detail in here to show
you what I have in mind software for
global collective decision making this
is the thing that humanity currently
does disastrously badly right now global
collective decision-making and that
involves getting the information to the
decision makers at the point that they
need it in a form that's useful and
maybe I should just leave that as that's
it that's the problem and that involves
lots of interesting tools visualizations
information systems access to data sets
open collaborative approaches to
building decision support tools anyway
you've got the idea so I should stop
there
take questions namespace for benefit was
give for a service mm-hmm yep yep and
there's still a lot of Fortran 77 code
in their code base there's been a
systematic attempt to bring it up to
fortran 95 which has modules and yeah
this is a problem they solve this the
same way they solved all the other
problems lots and lots of informal
communication across the lab yeah I
probably should have a more detailed
answer for you there's there's been a
systematic attempt to use code modules
when they became available in I think
this fort was it fortran 89 was it 90 I
don't membr one it was when they brought
in code modules so they're doing some of
that now and they want to be doing more
thanks to you